welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of obi-wan
kenobi episode four in which obi-wan
sneaks leia out of a fortress using the
same tactic i used to sneak chipotle
into an amc all of my favorite jackets
are now stained with tomatillo salsa
worth it let's break down this episode
shot by shot for all the star wars
easter eggs and visual details that you
might have missed and a reminder that
the best way you can support us here at
new rockstars is to check out our
obi-wan inspired empire's most wanted
shirt at newrockstarsmerch.com get in it
we'll give you the added option of
writing a custom shout out for our
obi-wan kenobi after shows now we gotta
start actually in the opening lucasfilm
title slide you know the one with the
red and the blue lights flashing over
metallic-based characters in this
episode they changed it to add our
friend ned b and lola our adorable
little droid who flashes blue here but
by the end of the episode we learn is
riva's tracker in the final shot with an
eyepiece glowing evil red the episode
opens with obi-wan wounded on the
shuttle ditch beam still reeling from
his roasting last episode now jabim is a
muddy mining world from the now
non-canon dark horse republic comics
later the empire comics and in those
stories a major site of a clone wars
battle but here we don't really see the
muddy surface only some polluted clouds
on their way in and the secret base that
is hidden in some caverns they cart
obi-wan through the landing bay passing
some other refugees on the path and
other volunteers like tala who help
these force-sensitive victims escape to
a peaceful life but among the luggage in
the gear looks like a rounded container
of some kind it does have a handle but
this might be the egg-shaped bassinet of
our lord and savior grogu if this is the
path for force sensitive refugees and
jedi survivors of border 66 this is
likely the same path grogu would have
been taken on to later end up with
denjarin 40 years from now now i guess
i'd be surprised for it to just be
sitting there loose unattended in the
lanny may 10 years after order 66 but
who knows maybe it's sealed shut and
they just can't get it open and they
don't know who or what is inside just
that it is important and i presume that
baby groku would have some kind of a
food supply then obi-wan plunges into
the back to tank and i like this back to
tank it's a good old-school back to tank
you know the vertical setup with the
wires and the harnesses the same kind
that luke had on hoth none of the luxury
tanning bed style back the tank that
boba fett had and i love this the
close-ups of obi-wan's burns cross-cut
with vader's scarred skin in his
simultaneous back to bath two brothers
in the same regenerative reflective
state darth vader burned obi-wan so bad
that he would know his pain and part of
that pain is the emotional pain felt the
next morning in a back to healing
session because we learned in the book
of boba fett that back to baths have a
sensory deprivation effect that causes
one to dwell on inner unresolved issues
so now obi-wan is jerking around in this
water triggered by vader's taunts and
his attacks and during this montage
vader also suddenly stirs in his tank
seeming to react to obi-wan somewhere
across the galaxy in another tank the
inner cutting editing implies that the
two might actually be sensing each
other's active presences in their
parallel baths and obi-wan unable to
deal with this trauma exits the bath
early which he might have also done to
sever any link vader might be forming to
his present location and the first thing
obi-wan says after the path
which reminds me of finn in the last
jedi who woke up in a back to healing
suit and the first line he says in that
movie is
where's ray and we cut from the
splashing back to fluid to the crashing
waves of ner looking upward at the
fortress inquisitorius obi-wan cuts his
watery healing session short but he
cannot escape water this episode taking
the plunge to enter the fortress and
fleeing the flood water in the lower
levels of it leia snaps at the
stormtroopers my father is a senator i
am a princess of alderaan echoing her
future haughty tones when she gets
captured by the empire again in a new
hope i'm a member of the imperial senate
on a diplomatic mission to alderaan tala
introduces obi-wan to roken i need your
help so does every kid making a rock
flow from here to course broken of
course referencing the jedi training
step of making stones float which yoda
made luke do an empire and ahsoka tries
to make groho do in the mandalorian and
roken says general
i'm sorry but that's not my problem yeah
he calls him general which is a reminder
of the true kenobi the general rank he
had in the republic army and really that
whole thing of jedi commanding and
fighting alongside clone troopers is
really part of what got him into that
mess rogan agrees to help because he had
a force-sensitive wife who was taken by
the empire and boots up a scrappy hollow
projector to show the ocean moon of nur
in its proximity to mustafar i love the
contrasting elemental imagery fire and
water and by the way that ship that
vader is on would likely be the
devastator that was the name of his
imperial star destroyer flagship that we
saw in the battle of scarif in rogue one
now the above water portion of the
fortress forms a pyramid matching
vader's castle even with two stubby
prongs at the top but the bulk of it is
below water as seen in the jedi fallen
order game overall it makes for a pretty
intimidating fortress descending wider
and wider into the ocean depths a
proverbial tip of the iceberg now in the
background of the scene is an astromech
droid that looks like r2d2 but it is not
it doesn't have the blue plating but i
just love when astromechs show up i love
these things this guy even that little
evil one that they pass as they leave
the fortress later on obi-wan proposes
we could take those speeders go in at
night you have some t-47s in the hangar
suicide yes t-47s are the same rebel
snow speeders in the battle of hoth and
empire strikes back we see these in
action later obi-wan struggles to force
pull a small object suggesting that
using the force at all opens his mind
back up to vader into his pain so it
just really hurts him to use it at all
but i like how we see him struggling in
the first act of this episode setting up
his badass mastery of it to control the
water towards the end it seems like two
big things have changed in obi-wan's
life between those points one having a
purpose to rescue leia and two get in a
sense of the stakes by seeing all of his
jedi friends with their corpses on
display rita tells leia we intercepted a
transmission on bellnam last year
bunch of talk of a secret network
a path yes ball knob is a mid-rim planet
that shows up in clone wars season 4
episode 3po in order to discover
pitroids are ruling over the locals on
this plane under our phony holographic
identity but this planet is known to be
home to a group of alien castaways and
it does make sense for it to be used as
part of the path but riva slams a chunk
of the wall with the jedi crest that we
saw in the mapuzo safe house meaning she
likely obliterated that safe house
destroying all the names and messages
from the other jedi survivors and more
concerningly removing it as the safe
house for future runaways that male can
send people to when tala arrives in her
imperial transport i like this the first
thing she passes on that hangar bay is a
cart filled with the fuel cells with the
glowing red cores the same ones that
rival later used to blow up weights t47
so in fact these are chekhov's fuel
cells while tala gets screened we get
this real in-your-face shot of an
officer in a billowy overcoat walking
right in front of the camera i clocked
this as a pretty new piece of imperial
outerwear but it was clearly put in here
just to set up obi-wan later using one
of these to hide leia and when the
security officer scans her the auramesh
on screen translates to captain tala
dureth unknown which is why this officer
was like you don't even go here and
tala's able to talk him down then i'm
your commanding officer and you will
address me sir yes sir of course but
perhaps i should just inform the grand
inquisitor of your insolence interesting
gamble by tala here because technically
the grand inquisitor's seat is absent
due to medical leave either yet to be
filled by another inquisitor or with
that power and grand inquisitor alien
and hopefully returns at some point to
stay true to the rebels continuity but
the fact that this officer does not know
that speaks to the inquisitor's secrecy
about their internal drama underwater
obi-wan uses a rebreather the same tech
that he and qui-gon use when swimming on
naboo and he swims past a blue vev
glider a shark-like creature that
calcusta swims past in this location in
jedi fallen order obi-wan's path this
episode pretty much parallels this stage
of the game and near the port you'll
notice a squid-like creature that might
be a vixus which also has a toothy maw
now the vixis and similar creatures like
the blixxis and the rathtar share a
common ancestry with the sarlacc which
is just another reminder that tatooine
was once an ocean-covered world and its
fauna have aquatic features reflecting
that like that whale carcass we saw in
episode one riva tries to scan leia's
mind it's the sister contest
you're strong echoing kylo ren's
struggle to read rey's mind and the
force awakens and riva says the braver
you've seen the more afraid you are i
learned that at a very young age as well
i had a droid when i was younger too it
was taken from me like everything else
yeah little hints at riva's past perhaps
as one of those young lady runaways from
that or66 prologue scene but i wonder
what was this droid she's talking about
could it have been who yang the
architect droid who taught jedi
younglings on the crucible in clone wars
huyang will return in the live-action
ahsoka series and one of those other
young lanes the wookie gunji is
appearing in bad batch he survived so if
riva was a temple runaway she might have
spent some time on the crucible with
huyang using netflix without expressvpn
is like going to the store and only
allowing yourself to shop on the
odd-numbered isles you're missing out on
those even number item goodies well
thanks to expressvpn for sponsoring this
video expressvpn lets you change your
online location so that you can access
geographically blocked content and get
access to all of the aisles of content
opening yourself up to whole new
libraries of shows and films from the
same streaming services that you're
already paying for watch studio ghibli
films on uk netflix just switch your
location to the uk refresh the page and
you're getting spirited away baby us
netflix subscribers can also unlock rick
and morty avatar the last airbender and
a bunch of other content viewers in the
uk can use it to unlock vikings or the
great british baking show or as you call
it buy golf which yes it's not available
on uk netflix
but it's your baking show you should
have it i like how easy expressvpn is to
use no confusion no wasted time the
whole thing runs fast just fire up the
app and connect with just one click it's
a top-rated vpn provider rated number
one by techradar find out how you can
get three months of expressvpn for free
by visiting expressvpn.com new rockstars
or clicking the link in the description
below obi-wan evades the secret droids
who are on patrol we actually saw some
secret droids used by the seventh sister
in rebels listen the sound this one
makes
[Music]
it's the same sound as the interrogator
droid that tortures leia in a new hope
and that interrogation and new hope
definitely matching the one leia nearly
goes through in this episode the calm
devices they use are the same
communicators that han luke used on the
death star in a new hope you'll also
notice in this episode they all use
their code cylinders which are actually
just originally costumed props from the
original trilogy but in rebels season
three we finally saw them used
practically which is something that they
continue to do in the mandalorian
obi-wan has to hide from some
stormtroopers who have some chatter
wow
[Music]
i love how even the stormtroopers are
creeped out by the layout in the depths
of this fortress they also may be
smelling some mummified bodies on the
ground floor but obi-wan starts to get a
hang of his force powers using them to
cast a noise that distracts the troopers
just as obi-wan does on the death star
in a new hope but obi-wan finds the
inner chamber and realizes the dark
truth this place isn't a fortress
it's a tune and i love how ewing
delivers this with the same cadence in
dread as that's no moon
it's a space station the jedi corpses
are suspended in an amber-like substance
which unlike carbonite might allow the
inquisitors to repurpose their corpses
to trap jedi the way the grand
inquisitor does with luminar and
dooley's corpse and rebels this encasing
could also be how they extract some
m-count rich blood from them for some
clonin and those lightsabers on display
on the red shelf in the upper room are
likely the lightsabers of these killed
jedi now counting all the cells that i
could see on the upper level in the
lower level i s made about 48 16 on the
ground level 32 on the upper level we
only see a handful of them in the actual
cells in the wide shot from the end of
the corridor on the right is an angry
male who could be either pablo jill from
attack of the clones or coleman cassaj
from the jedi council in revenge of the
sith whose name also appeared on a list
of names of jedi fugitives in the 2017
charles soldier darth vader comics
alongside quinlin voss and the left of
that wide shot is a male with long hair
who does look a lot like quinlan boss
but i think obi-wan would have paused to
look at him longer and i just doubt they
would bring up quinn linvas last episode
as a living survivor just to reveal him
dead like this like in passing but the
real heartbreaker on these is a kassian
named tara sanube an elder jedi master
from clone wars who once helped ahsoka
tano find her lightsaber a mentor to
various young liens over the years
including ones like saifo diaz and dooku
he was known for carrying a white or
silver lightsaber in a cane it just
sucks to see that this guy died and i'm
actually wondering if he might have
helped some young ladies escape order 66
maybe even on the crucible with who yang
and riva might have betrayed him and
turned him in in order to gain
acceptance to the inquisitors that's
just my theory as obi-wan walks past
these cells there are a few new faces
we're still trying to identify like
there's one with an odd square shaped
head piece and the first i thought was
george lucas's character from revenge of
the sith but no completely different
headpiece and i don't think that guy was
a jedi there's another one with thick
padded armor and then a close-up of a
woman's face in shock and then another
woman in a poncho with a necklace i
wouldn't be surprised if one of these
two women might be rokin's
force-sensitive wife then this young
lane boy who is actually someone we've
seen before he's credited as actors the
twin brothers jonathan hoe and oliver ho
who were also credited as playing one of
the younglings in the order 66 flashback
in the episode 1 prologue so if riva was
part of that group this would mean this
is one of her friends who has frozen in
youth for 10 years as obi-wan leaves
this quarter there is a bald
dark-skinned man on the upper right who
might be mace windu but this guy in the
cell has a right hand that is clearly
visible and remember anakin sliced off
mace's right arm and i just doubt that
they would leave mace's faint just in
passing like this without a close-up of
them now there are plenty of other
jedi's who have been hunted by
inquisitors or by vader or clone
troopers who might be here i mentioned
luminara and dooley but of course we saw
plo koon kiari mundi ayla sakura de
pablava syndrolic all these characters
are dead there's also jar to paul from
fallen order who might be among these
meanwhile riva straps leia to this
torture rack which is very similar to
the device and the chamber in jedi
fallen order that was used to torture
seer agenda if this is something a lot
of inquisitors had to go through maybe
this is something reba has experienced
herself which is why she's so willing to
put leia through it but tala is able to
distract riva away telling her they're
on florum
the network runs out of the certain
sector yes forum is an outer rim planet
that also came up in clone wars as a
barren planet serving as the residence
of the pirate gang of hondu onaka so
tala is not just saying any planet she's
trying to draw the inquisitors to a
remote planet out in the boonies where
pirates might attack him obi-wan's able
to rescue leia by shutting off the
lights and going to work with his blue
lightsaber imagery totally paralleling
the force unleash ii e3 trailer footage
of starkiller which sam whitware whose
likeness they used in addition to him
being the voice of maul tweeting
yesterday that obi-wan took his legs and
his dance moves this is also an example
of obi-wan embracing quinlan's words of
wisdom from last episode using the
darkness to find the way leia tells him
that she didn't snitch and obi-wan says
i know
and as han told us i know is star wars
for i love you i love you
i know when obi-wan and leia are finally
spotted at classic star wars imperial
alarm rings
[Music]
it's him i love how obi-wan uses
defensive maneuvers to take out the
stormtroopers in that secret droid using
the stormtrooper's blast to take out the
droid and then deflecting all the other
blasts him getting more and more
confident as this episode goes meanwhile
riva's reinforcements include a black
and red armored purge trooper and they
take on obi-wan in this glass-lined
corridor and you see his rising comfort
level with the saber he does a no-look
backswing deflection of the trooper
behind him and then actively batting a
blast like a baseball at a control panel
obi-wan finally musters up his strength
to use the force to slow the breaking
glass in the leaking water and then as
they come through the door he directs
those cracks back toward them and floods
them controlling the flow of the water
just like how in jedi fallen order darth
vader was able to use the force to hold
back the water in the same way the fifth
brother and the fourth sister charged
down the main concourse passing right by
tala and obi-wan with leia tucked in the
coat you can see them in the background
there but there are a lot of weird
things going on in this shot like there
are these two overlit stormtroopers who
come into the frame on the left side
after the characters leave it and then
there's just various groupings of
officers and all of these groupings just
look plated in most of these large
locations are of course shot in the
volume which is awesome looking usually
but i think in this case what throws it
is that one random squad of
stormtroopers in the distant background
marching leftward across frame and if
you were to map out their vector they're
really just marching toward the window
wall to look at fish i guess like
clearly the people made this scene just
wanted general background movement to
show the chaos but this is also in a
shot where they wanted us to look at
tala and ben and leia there and i'm not
saying this to be overly critical i just
think when shots look weird like this
there's usually a very subtle logical
reason why and i think it helps us to
better appreciate the overall very
difficult task of vfx artists when we
identify that specific reason instead of
just shrugging it all off with a big it
all looks bad doesn't all look bad
overall this design of the setting is
gorgeous but it's just in this case i
think the design outweighs the
practicality a little bit which at the
end of the day i think is okay riva
catches up to them in screams
yeah she's doing her best impression of
kylo ren yelling at finn in the force
awakens
sully and wade drop in in their t47s
leading to this shootout where this poor
mouse droid gets hit and recoils
steering back in the same way as it does
when chewie roars at one in a new hope
tala obi-wan and leia cram into the back
seat of sully's t-47 and wade holds off
reba just a bit too long allowing riva
to chuck a fuel cell at him boom riva
does not send all those hanging tie
fighters or probes or anyone after
sully's t47 which seems completely
bonkers until we realize in the next
scene that she intentionally let leia
and obi-wan escape so that they could
track her with lola to cha-beam or
wherever the next step on the path is
i've speculated the path could lead to
places like krait or maybe tython which
would explain why there's that jedi
beacon on tithon now remember we did see
revo holding lola earlier presumably
that was when she slipped the tracker on
it and i assume that she did this as a
contingency in case leia and obi-wan
were able to escape because otherwise
she would have no reason to chase them
down and try to attack them i love this
vader storms into the boardroom marching
faster than i think we've ever seen
vader charge in live action and it is
pretty terrifying to see a move this
fast but ultimately i love the elemental
imagery around vader right now he ended
last episode surrounded by fire now he
is surrounded by gloomy water taking him
back to his back to bath in the opening
images fire represents his division from
obi-wan water represents his reunion
with him and as they mourn wade on the
freighter lola's eyepiece which
previously glowed blue matching the
protective color of obi-wan's lightsaber
now glows red the color of the hostile
blades of riva and vader who now are
watching very closely another reminder
to check out our merch options over at
newrockstarsmerch.com you can follow me
on instagram and twitter at ea boss
follow me rockstar subscribe to
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you
[Music]